[Music]
my husband was killed in a far away
land this place is so bar and I can't
understand what he would have seen out
here yeah she is far away
down welcome to Australia this should be
interesting it's all very Outback
Adventure isn't it I'm not saying it's
for
everyone
who are you I M he's all Aline I'm not
good with the
children when we first come to this land
you look but you not see now you get her
eyes open for the first
time I am going to bring Far Away Downs
back to
life Nala will you help me
yes
Sergeant Callahan on the police there's
a half blood Aboriginal child out here
somewhere run I thought we might put him
in the good hands of the
church get off my
property to save this house I need money
out of here your cattle's worth more
than your
land what are you doing
Cy a cattle station is like a country
and you have no one to protect
it
we can't let them win we won't the now
we going to do a drive with just me and
my two
men that's plenty old enough he is a
child if he doesn't get you'll have no
country no
Story the Japanese are coming we must
evacuate whatever happens whatever it
takes we'll be together I believe
you the only thing you really own is
your
story just trying to live a good
[Music]
one